wenn mehr über die Familie ihnen
kritisiert wurde immer noch große
[Musik]
Politik und mit allem
der Boden
wegstanden und es ist nochmal für die
betroffene sondern früh ausgesellschaft
politischen Schweiz sondern beim Speedy
nachhaltig ein bisschen Angst
und genau
[Musik]
online gesehen
wurde mehr oder weniger dieses Gefühl
bezüglich vermehrt sicher verliert
worden befindet sich noch schwieriger
Bedürfnis nach Informationen Pandemie
Jungs
Schweiz
Audi Institutionen
die die die dyname die normalen die war
nur mit der Retter zum Teiler die
us-kranzgesellschaft abgestempelt und
vorverurteilt worden
Corona Leugner geht jetzt noch nicht
reden wenn sie Menschen
stimmen nicht verstehen
Phänomen
kritische Menschen und ich kann immer
für mich
und Finger
ich glaube wir hatten dann
einfach mit mit zwei Farben ab mit dem
Diener Verschwörungstheorie so logisch
dass man mit heutigen Wissen stand
Ausklang ist und entspannter gesät aber
trotzdem falsche Informationen und
Verschwörungstheorien Motive
zulassen und Begriffe dazwischen wird
wieder die ganze Reportage begleiten
eine interessante Befunde für deine
Politikwissenschaftler Michael Bank
Petersen er hätte 21 andere sucht
inwiefern Vorteil zwischen zwei Lager
gekämpft und umkämpft
Studie zeigt das umkämpft die verkämpft
aus unintelligent und nicht
vertrauenswürdig sie Wagner Worte die
ablehnen die Haut kämpfte sich im
Vergleich zu anderen diskriminierte
Gruppe 2 Jahre sind
die Ausgrenzung wo man subjektive
Tendenz von Gesellschaft zurückgezogen
politisch aktiv wurde seine Person ist
Petra und wir treffen zusammen
freut mich bereits
80 80
sondern aus Bürgerrechtsbewegung
damit begründet Patrick aufrecht an der
Demo so vorgestellt ich weiß dass sehr
viel
mit Politik und mit Wale
[Musik]
und solange das System noch funktioniert
kritisiert Machtkonzentration auf
nationaler Ebene
und allgemein weniger zentralistische
Strukturen drum fingen sie zum Beispiel
der Lehrplan eine 20 Curry abgeschafft
so habe es öffentlich rechtlicher Radio
und Fernseh wo ihren Augen sowieso
nochmal Panik verbreitet aufrecht fängt
da klang
wissenschaftskritischen
politischen Spektrum Film
verantwortlich ist natürlich die Corona
Verwendung du bist handlicher passiert
muss es besser machen muss ja ich habe
ihn nicht gemacht
das bleibt für euch übrig im Hinblick
auf das Thema was ist für das Gefühl von
der Politik ich bin enttäuscht von der
Schweiz
[Musik]
da
weiße Ablehnung gegenüber mehr als
Schuhen die vom Messer auf Gespräch
zeigen die Leute Politik Nummer
menschenkritiker
demonstriert auf dem Bundesplatz
Maßnahme kritische gruppiere aber nicht
Ukraine
geht genau gleich wieder Pandemie die
etablierte Experten und Politik
aber nicht bleiben keine
Waffenlieferungen keine Aktionen gegen
irgendwelche Nationen denn diese
Sanktionen schaden nur dem einfachen
Mann
[Applaus]
die vermehren das ist Thema aber bei mir
schwierig Fingern
Frisuren und dann
habe ich zu schmieren
ja
das war Tag später
Auswirkungen
Gesellschaft hat
für mich gesund ja aber früher fixe
Termin gesehen
das sieht sehr wichtige Leute
einzigartig
aber mehr da wo wachsen
extremes braucht
schlagen
Erkenntnis dass die Leute erkennen
okay du weißt du bist wiederholen
und wenn das nicht passiert
ich hätte nie mehr irgendetwas gewiss
[Musik]
er Gesellschaften
verschlagen worden
[Musik]
das waren noch Zeiten als
klimaaktivistinnen und Aktivisten zu
Tausenden auf Schweizer Straßen
aufmarschierten und so sehen Demos heute
aus so ein Tagesschau im Mai 2019
durch das Zertifikat werden Menschen in
zwei Kategorien eingeteilt Partnerin ist
mit ihrer Kritiker der Maßnahmen zum
Gesicht von der freie Link geworden
und die linke Politik kritisiert der
freie linker wird nachgesagt dass sie
Verschwörungstheorie verbreite nur
Rechtsextremismus verharmlosen
wurde
juristisch
14 Jahre im Vorstand ist sie hätten
die 54 Jahre gibt's Bayern
[Musik]
guten Abend miteinander
mit der ehemaligen fraktionsgespäne
fraktionslos im Stadtrat
gut sauber
[Musik]
kritisieren
und Bürger profitiert und auf
Gesundheitssystem bezogen
[Musik]
Spaltung ist die dritte Pandemie
fast alleinige Kompetenzen hat und die
Grundrechte eingeschränkt werden sollten
wir einander zuhören und wieder den
gewohnten
pluralistischen Diskurs betreiben und
jetzt sind
die jeweilige Informationsquellen
mache ja da Französisch eigentlich schon
Spanisch oder
Latina
Kenntnisnahme Schweiz
gegangen
Gesellschaft für Zukunft das ist das
allererisch gesehen dass man besser
loggen
tschüss
wie diskutieren
Gesellschaft von der Nähe von Politik
abwenden wieso muss es so radikal
aussieht
besorgniserregender oder
Brücke auf Finanzen
irgendwie eine Einbahnstraße die Dynamik
das muss digitale Echo Hammer saubere
regelmäßig treibt
seine schnurren aber jetzt bin ich
gespannt
sie Kommentar und ähm
[Musik]
90 %.
das nennen das sagt einfach
ja und ähm
[Gelächter]
geil machen ich werde gefragt
also machen